يتحول الان الى عمار عمر الغول في امام
مستشفى المعمداني في وسط غزه لكن قبل ذلك
دعوني فقط انوه الى هذه الاخبار العاجله
مراسل الجزيره يتحدث عن وقوع 25 شهيدا في
قصف اسرائيل استهدف منزلا لعائله حماده في
حي التفاح شرقي
مدينه غزه وهذا طبعا مع استمرار الغارات
الاسرائيليه في هذا اليوم الئ
او 115 يوما من الحرب الاسرائيليه اتحول
اليك اذا اسماعيل واخر التطورات الميدانيه
التي رصدتها
لنا دائما ما تكون اخر التطورات الميدانيه
قصف اسرائيلي لكن اليوم انتقلنا من مستشفى
الشفاء مرغب تحت القصف الاسرائيلي ورصاص
قوات الاحتلال الى مستشفى المعمداني هذه
المنطقه الغربيه التي تحولت الى منطقه
خطره بعد تح بعد تمركز قوات الاحتلال قرب
مفترق الاتصالات بالاضافه الى تمركز قوات
الاحتلال داخل مدينه عرفات التابعه للشرطه
الفلسطينيه في منطقه جنوب قطاع غزه القصف
الاسرائيلي متواصل في منطقه الصناعه الان
عائلات تصل الى مستشفى المعمداني تناشد
بانتشال بعض جثامين الشهداء وبعض الاصابات
التي بقت قرب طرنبه فارس في منطقه محيط
الجماعات استهدفت الطائرات الاسرائيليه
سياره في ذي ذاك المكان وحتى هذه اللحظه
لا تستطيع العائله اقتراب من طرنبه فارس
بسبب تواجد قوات الاحتلال في محيط مفترق
الازهر ومحيط مفترق انصار وتلك المنطقه
التي ت يعني اصبحت مركز عمليات لقوات
الاحتلال الان وفق ما اخبرت العائله ان
هناك طفله او طفلتين هما الناجيين من
القصف الاسرائيلي لهذه السياره ق قرب
طرنبه فارس ايضا الغارات الاسرائيليه
استهدفت ايه تجمعا للمواطنين قرب مفترق
الصناعه وهناك عدد من الاصابات والشهداء
وصلوا الى مستشفى المعمداني حتى هذه
اللحظه وفق الاهالي ايضا لا يستطيعون
انتشال الجثامين بالاضافه الى حصار قوات
الاحتلال المضر على منطقه تجمع الصناعه
ومنطقه تجمع الجامعات بالاضافه الى منطقه
تجمع مدارس تتبع للنور ومدرسه اسما مدرسه
الرمال
الاعداديه في تلك المنطقه التي وقع بها
عدد من الشهداء صباح اليوم عره شهداء
نتيجه ايضا القصف الاسرائيلي بالاضافه الى
ذلك ننتقل الى المنطقه الشرقيه لمدينه غزه
منطقه التفاح التي شهدت قصفا على عائله
حماده حتى هذه اللحظه الشهداء اسفل
الانقاض قرابه ال 25 شهيدا سقطوا او
ارتقوا في هذه الغاره الاسرائيليه على
منطقه التفاح غارات اسرائيليه ايضا من
مدفعيه قوات الاحتلال مختلفه على منطقه حي
الشيخ رضوان هذه المنطقه التي اصبحت ايضا
مسرحا للعمليات هذه ال اليوم والليله
الماضيه هو من اكثر دمويه على مدينه غزه
قصف اسرائيلي متواصل بالاضافه الى غارات
عنيفه وتدمير اكثر من 20 بنايه سكنيه حتى
هذه اللحظه في مختلف المناطق ووقوع عشرات
الشهداء على المفترقات بالتحديد في
المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه مفترق الصناعه
ومنطقه طرنبه فارس ومنطقه مفترق جامعه
الازهر هذه المناطق الان التي تحولت الى
مصرح عمليات ولا تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه او
حتى طواقم الدفاع المدني او حتى طواقم
الهلال الاحمر التوجه الى ذاك المكان
وانتشال الاصابات وانتشال الشهداء
بالاضافه الى ذلك نتحدث عن منظومه صحيه قد
تك قد
تكون مال الساعات القادمه سقوطا في مستشفى
الشفاء الكثير من الاطباء نزحوا نتيجه
القصف الاسرائيلي والكثير من المرضى ايضا
اخلوا من تلك المنطقه بسبب القصف
الاسرائيلي المتواصل الان مجمع الشفاء
الطبي بات في خطر حقيقي من سقوط المنظومه
الصحيه اثر الحصار الاسرائيلي المتواصل
على محيط تلك المنطقه واطلاق القذائف
الصرخيه المتواصل ايضا على محيط تلك
المنطقه الحاله بتت صعبه في غرب مدينه غزه
بالتحديد في محيط مجمع الشفاء
الطبي شكرا جزيلا لك اسماعيل الغوله تحول
اليه